people should not have to worry about
inflation as they go about their daily
business
that's why we've been raising interest
rates and did so again today
low and stable inflation is the Bedrock
of a stable economy
a predictable economy in which people
can go about their lives and plan for
their future with confidence
an economy in which hard-earned money
keeps its value
if we do not act forcefully now it will
be worse later on
and as the forecast we are publishing
today's shows
it is a tough road ahead
the sharp increase in Energy prices
caused by Russia's invasion of Ukraine
has made us poorer as a nation
the level of economic activity is likely
to be flat and even fall for some time
but the economy will recover and
inflation will fall
we cannot have afraid pretend to know
what will happen to gas prices that
depends on the war in in Ukraine
but from where we stand now we think
inflation will begin to fall back from
the middle of next year
probably quite sharply
now to make sure that happens bank rate
may have to go up further over the
coming months
we can't make promises about future
interest rates
but based on where we stand today
we think bank rate will have to go up by
less than currently priced in financial
markets
and that's important
because for instance it means that the
rates on new fixed term mortgages should
not need to rise as they have done